what do you think in general that llama
was open sourced I just uh did a
conversation with uh with Mark
Zuckerberg and he's all in on open
source
who would have thought that Mark
Zuckerberg would be the good guy
I mean it
would have thought anything in this
world
it's hard to know
but open source to you ultimately
is a good thing here
undoubtedly
you know
what's ironic about all these AI safety
people is they are going to build the
exact thing they fear
these we need to have one model that we
control and align this is the only way
you end up paper clipped there's no way
you end up pay-per-clip if everybody has
an AI so open sourcing is the way to
fight the paperclip maximizer absolutely
it's the only way you think you're going
to control it you're not going to
control it so the criticism you have for
the AI safety folks is that there is a
belief and a desire for control yeah and
that belief and desire
for centralized control of dangerous AI
systems is not good Sam Altman won't
tell you that gpt4 has 220 billion
parameters and is a 16-way mixture model
with eight sets of Weights who did you
have to murder to get that information
all right I mean look but yes everyone
at open AI knows what I just said was
true right now uh ask the question
really you know it upsets me when I like
gpt2 when openai came out with gpt2 and
raised a whole fake AI safety thing
about that I mean now the model is
laughable
like they they used AI safety to Hype up
their company and it's disgusting
or the flip side of that is they used a
relatively weak model in retrospect to
explore how do we do AI safety correctly
how do we release things how do we go
through the process I don't I don't know
if I don't know I don't know how much
they're charitable interpretation I
don't know how much hype there is in the
AI safety honestly oh there's so much I
at least on Twitter I don't know maybe
Twitter's not realized but it's not real
life come on in terms of hype I mean I
don't
I think open AI has been finding an
interesting balance between transparency
and putting value on um AI safety you
don't think you think just go
all out open source so do a llama
so do like open source this is a tough
question which is open source both the
the base the foundation model and the
fine-tuned one so like that the model
that can be ultra racist and dangerous
and like tell you how to build a nuclear
weapon oh my God have you met humans
right like half of these AI I haven't
met most humans I this makes this this
this allows you to meet every human yeah
I know but half of these AI alignment
problems are just human alignment
problems and that's what's also so scary
about The Language they use it's like
it's not the machines you want to align
it's me
but here's the thing
it makes it very accessible to ask
very uh
questions where the answers have
dangerous consequences if you were to
act on them
I mean yeah welcome to the world well no
for me there's a lot of friction if I
want to find out how to uh
I don't know blow up something no
there's not a lot of friction that's so
easy no like what do I search Days Bing
or do I which search engine I use no
there's like lots of stuff no it feels
like I have to go first off first off
anyone who's stupid enough to search for
how to blow up a building in my
neighborhood is not smart enough to
build a bomb right are you sure about
that yes
I I feel like I feel like a language
model
makes it more accessible for that person
who's not smart enough to do they're not
gonna they're not gonna build a bomb
trust me the the the the people the
people who are incapable of figuring out
how to like ask that question a bit more
academically and get a real answer from
it are not capable of procuring the
materials which are somewhat controlled
to build a bomb
no I think Allah makes it more
accessible to people with money without
the technical know-how right to to build
like you do you really need to know how
to build a bomb to build a bomb you can
hire people you can find like oh you can
hire people to build up you know what I
was asking this question on my stream
like can Jeff Bezos hire a hit man
probably not
but a language model
can probably help you out
yeah and you'll still go to jail right
like it's not like the language model is
God like the language model it's like
it's you literally just hired someone on
Fiverr
but you use it okay okay gpt4 in terms
of finding Hitman is like asking five or
how to find it I understand but don't
you think wikiHow you know wikiHow but
don't you think gpt5 will be better
because don't you think that information
is out there on the internet I mean yeah
and I think that if someone is actually
serious enough to hire a hitman or build
a bomb they'd also be serious enough to
find the information I don't think so I
think it makes it more accessible if you
have if you have enough money to buy
Hitman I think it decreases the friction
of how hard is it to find that kind of
Hitman I I honestly think this the
there's a jump
in uh
ease and scale of how much harm you can
do and I don't mean harm with language I
mean harm with actual violence what
you're basically saying is like okay
what's going to happen is these people
who are not intelligent are going to use
machines to augment their intelligence
and now intelligent people and machines
intelligence is scary intelligent agents
are scary when I'm in the woods the
scariest animal to meet is a human right
no no no there's look there's like nice
California humans like I see you're
wearing like you know street clothes and
Nikes all right fine you look like
you've been a human who's been in the
woods for a while yeah I'm more scared
of you than a bear that's what they say
about the Amazon when you go to the
Amazon it's the human tribes oh yeah
so intelligence is scary right so to to
ask this question a generic way you're
like what if we took everybody who you
know maybe has um ill intention but is
not so intelligent and gave them
intelligence
right
so
we should have intelligence control of
course we should only give intelligence
to good people and that is the
absolutely horrifying idea so do the
best defense is actually the best
defense is to give more intelligence to
the good guys and intelligence give
intelligence to everybody give
intelligence to everybody you know what
it's not even like guns right like
people say this about guns you know
what's what's the best defense against a
bad guy with a gun good guy with a gun
like I kind of subscribe to that but I
really subscribe to that with
intelligence
yeah in a fundamental way I I agree with
you but there's just feels like so much
uncertainty and so much can happen
rapidly that you can lose a lot of
control you can do a lot of damage oh no
we can lose control yes yes thank God
yeah I hope we can I hope they lose
control
I want them to lose control more than
anything else
I think when you lose control you can do
a lot of damage but you can do more
damage when you centralize and hold on
to control is the point centralized and
held control is tyranny all right I will
always I don't like Anarchy either but
I'll always take Anarchy over tyranny
Anarchy have a chance
this human civilization we've got going
on is quite interesting I mean I agree
with you so do you open source
is the way forward here so you admire
what Facebook is doing here or what Matt
is doing with the release of them yeah a
lot I lost I've lost 80 000 last year
investing in meta and when they released
llama I'm like yeah whatever man that
was worth it it's worth it
do you think Google and uh open AI with
Microsoft will match what what meta is
doing or no
so if I were a researcher why would you
want to work at open AI like you know
you're just you're on the bad team like
I mean it like you're on the bad team
who can't even say that gpt4 has 220
billion parameters it's a closed source
to use the bad team
not only closed Source I'm not saying
you need to make your model weights open
I'm not saying that I totally understand
we're keeping our model weights closed
because that's our product right that's
fine
I'm saying like because of AI safety
reasons we can't tell you the number of
billions of parameters in the model
that's just the bad guys
just because you're mocking AI safety
doesn't mean it's not real oh of course
is it possible that these things can
really do a lot of damage that we don't
know oh my God yes intelligence is so
dangerous be it human intelligence or
machine intelligence intelligence is
dangerous to put machine intelligence is
so much easier to deploy at scale like
rapidly
like what okay if you have human-like
bots on Twitter all right
and you have like a thousand of them
create a whole narrative
like you can manipulate millions of
people but you mean like the
intelligence agencies in America are
doing right now yeah but they're not
doing it that that well it feels like
you can do a lot they're doing it pretty
well
I think they're doing a pretty good job
I I suspect they're not nearly as good
as a bunch of uh gbt fueled Bots could
be well I mean of course they're looking
into the latest Technologies for control
of people of course but I think there's
a George Haas type character that can do
a better job than the entirety of them
you don't think so why no and I'll tell
you why the George hotz character can't
and I thought about this a lot with
hacking right like I can find exploits
in web browsers I probably still can I
mean I was better when I was 24 but the
thing that I lack is the ability to
slowly and steadily deploy them over
five years and this is what intelligence
agencies are very good at right
intelligence agencies don't have the
most sophisticated technology
they just have endurance endurance
yeah
the financial backing
and the infrastructure for the endurance
so the more we can decentralize power
like you could make an argument by the
way that nobody should have these things
and I would defend that argument I would
I would like saying look llms and Ai and
machine intelligence can cause a lot of
harm so nobody should have it and I will
respect someone philosophically with
that position just like I will respect
someone philosophically with the
position that nobody should have guns
right but I will not respect
philosophically which it with with
Only The Trusted authorities should have
access to this yeah who are The Trusted
authorities you know what I'm not
worried about alignment between
AI company and their machines I'm
worried about alignment between me and
AI company
what do you think
earlierkowski would say to you
oh this is really against open source I
know and
thought about this thought about this
and
I think this comes down to
a repeated misunderstanding of political
power by the rationalists
interesting
I think that Elias yutkowski is scared
of these things and I am scared of these
things too everyone should be scared of
these things these things are scary
but now you ask about the two possible
Futures one where a small trusted
centralized group of people has them and
the other where everyone has them
and I am much less scared of the second
future than the first
well there's a small trusted group of
people that have control of our nuclear
weapons
there's a difference again a nuclear
weapon cannot be deployed tactically and
a nuclear weapon is not a defense
against a nuclear weapon
except maybe in some philosophical mind
game kind of way
but AI is different different how
exactly okay let's say the
intelligence agency deploys a million
bots on Twitter or a thousand bots on
Twitter to try to convince me of a point
imagine I had a powerful AI running on
my computer saying okay uh nice psyop
nice psyop nice psyop okay here's a
psyop I filtered it out for you
yeah I mean so you have fundamentally
hope for that
for the for the defense of psyop I'm not
even like I don't even mean these things
in like truly horrible ways I mean these
things in straight up like ad blocker
right yeah sure bad blocker I don't want
ads
they're always finding you know imagine
I had an AI
lock all the ads for me so you believe
in the
the power of the people to always create
a knob blocker
yeah I mean I I kind of share that
belief I have that's one of the deepest
optimisms I have is just like there's a
lot of good guys
so to give you don't you shouldn't hand
pick them just throw out powerful
technology out there and the good guys
will outnumber and outpower the bad guys
yeah I'm not even gonna say there's a
lot of good guys I'm saying that good
outnumber is bad right good out number
is bad in skill and performance
definitely in skill and performance
probably just a number two probably just
in general I mean if you know if you
believe philosophically and democracy
you obviously believe that
um that good out number is bad and like
the only if you give it to a small
number of people
there's a chance you gave it to good
people but there's also a chance you
gave it to bad people if you give it to
everybody
well if good out numbers bad then you
definitely gave it to more good people
than bad
that's really interesting so that's on
the safety grounds but then also of
course there's other motivations like
you don't want to give away your secret
sauce
well that's I mean I I look I respect
capitalism I don't think that I think
that it would be polite for you to make
model architectures open source and
fundamental breakthroughs open source I
don't think you have to make weights
open source you know what's interesting
is that
like there's so many possible
trajectories in human history where you
could have the next Google be open
source so for example
I don't know if that connection is
accurate but you know Wikipedia made a
lot of interesting decisions not to put
ads like Wikipedia is basically open
source you could think of it that way
yeah and like that's one of the main
websites on the internet and like it
didn't have to be that way it could have
been like Google could have created
Wikipedia put ads on it you could
probably run amazing ads now on
Wikipedia you wouldn't have to keep
asking for money but it's interesting
right so llama open source llama
derivatives of Open Source lava might
win the internet
I sure hope so I hope to see another era
you know the kids today don't know how
good the internet used to be
and I don't think this is just all right
come on like everyone's nostalgic for
their past but I actually think the
internet before small groups of
weaponized corporate and government
interests took it over was a beautiful
place